[Music]
as Wicked Wolf I would really appreciate
it if you would not ask where I am at
literally 10 seconds passed when I was
planning to be
here when it hits the five minute Mark
that is one
thing but for crying out loud I'm a
human being and timing is not my strong
suit hi hey
everybody ah
hope everybody is doing
well there we go ah if you
celebrated uh Christmas I hope you had a
lovely one if you didn't I hope you had
a very nice day yesterday
regardless and hope everybody is doing
well um you're still stuck with me on on
the headset mic because I haven't had
the chance to replace my mid-range mic
yet I got to do that I got to do a lot
of stuff oh it never
stops anyway welcome if this is your
first time joining me uh on stream
reminder that uh while I will try and
keep up with the chat as it goes the
only things that will guarantee that I
will see your uh comment and or question
is to do it as a super chat which will
also get you a little heart of
appreciation from me so let's see oh we
have a new channel member Owen wildish
thank you very much became a snazzy
supporter very nice CK plays thank you
for the Super Chat very much shout out
to my friend Gabe Asher a shout out to
Gabe Asher
indeed you have been shouted in an
outward
fashion
huzzah I don't know why I felt the need
to do that uh who is the Ronnie I've
heard a lot about it really recently oh
God the Ronnie is a character from
classic era Doctor Who she
appeared initially I think with in
during the sixth doctor's era she
basically was an attempt to give uh a
Refresh on a villainous Time Lord
because the Masters shtick was uh stale
and he had kind of become
non-threatening uh so rather than try
and Revitalize the master or indeed
retire him because he was still hanging
around they brought in another uh evil
Time Lord and that was Lani she made two
appearances in the classic era I think
she's been used in some big finish audio
stuff she's not a very good character or
at least not in any of the stuff I've
seen her in fans have been speculating
about literally every single female
vaguely mysterious character that has
ever been introduced into Doctor Who and
gone I bet it's the Ronnie and it's
never the freaking Ronnie someday it
will be just to prove me wrong but like
it's not the Ronnie oh hey Meg good to
see you and thank
you somebody love lovely gave me this
shirt ah so let's see is uh is it weird
to have low self-esteem but not have any
body issues but yeah there's plenty of
stuff to have low self-esteem about your
um your abilities your talents
your uh sense of your own worth and what
you add to the world your confidence in
your abilities to meet any of the goals
you have there's plenty of stuff reasons
to have uh low self-esteem other than
body issues the big one of course just
being you feel the societal pressure of
a bull crap system that is designed to
grind you down
so we all deal with that
regardless of anything else H I can't
believe uh we're just a few days away
from entering the new year or in my home
dad's birthday he was born on New Year's
Day ah there's always some that's the
thing there's always like this deal ah
this was the first baby of the new year
yeah and after that initial one nobody
cares it's just like oh right dad's
birthday oh you're all hung over not
necessarily not everyone drinks on New
Year's Eve I do not always sometimes I
do I we'll move
on today's The Exorcist 50th Anniversary
cool don't
care it's it's an overrated
movie
uh please know Doctor Who Christmas
special spoilers I forgot about in the
Christmas cast uh yeah actually that's a
good point given that it only aired
yesterday um yeah I I'm going to say we
need
to we need to put the kibos on spoiler
discussions or spoiler questions about
that episode in particular it's been
long enough that I I I'm open to
answering questions about the earlier
three specials um and if you want to ask
me some broad questions about the
Christmas special like I don't know what
I thought of X performance or whatever
um I'll do that but let's try and be be
careful because it did just air
yesterday so let's try and avoid the
spoilers if it is at all
possible stop saying it's the Ron it's
not gonna happen paraphrasing from my
favorite team movie Mean Girls which
turns 20 and 2024
uh stop trying to make the Ronnie happen
it's not going to
happen H ver should be a motivational
speaker I'd like to get paid with those
people get paid I take
that uh how is uh your dog Meg she doing
good so scruffy little butthead she's
great I love her why do you think the
Exorcist is overrated cuz speaking as
someone who was raised in the um horror
environment that it helped spawn since
it doesn't hold up as a particularly
scary or taboo pushing thing which is
what what it was at the time like it's a
well-made film I'm not trying to say
that it isn't but it was it it got its
reputation on the back of shock it was a
shock horror film not in the way we now
think of shock horror with like the most
disturbing possible Gore but like shock
in the sense of dealing with these
religious Notions and targeting a young
girl in the way that that movie did was
taboo at the time especially uh in
anything that wasn't a clearcut
exploitation film it was a shock horror
movie because for the level of prestige
that it had from the pedigree of the
people making it and the obvious skill
that went into it it was dealing with
subject matter that well movies this
well made don't deal with that sort of
thing but the shock is gone 50 years
later who is shocked by this thing I've
I've only known a couple of people who
were not alive when it came out who
found it shocking or disturbing and they
were pretty much all raised Catholic so
I will readily Grant it probably still
has an impact on people if it can tap
into their own religious background
beliefs Andor trauma but speaking of
someone who is lacking in those uh
particular things yeah no it's like it's
it's fine it's a little too
long favorite Christmas
movie I don't I mean the traditional one
that I'm sure to watch every year here
is Love Actually that that and a handful
of Christmas specials that's probably
the only movie I go out of my way to
watch every every year at
Christmas which six doctor story do you
think is better Vengeance on vus or mind
warp mind warp with the asterisk that
what happens at the very end of Mind
warp is messed up and I hate it
um but overall mind warp is just a
better story than Vengeance on
Barrow I still don't believe the fman
would have survived the snow crushing
them it's it's a movie and especially
given that they come back in the sequel
which is practically a Looney Tunes uh
movie I don't know what to tell
you the original Miracle in 34th Street
best Christmas film it's good I like it
which adaptation of the Grinch is better
C batch or
Carrie
neither neither they're
they're no neither I refused to pick I
was gonna say I was going to try and
make an argument but the the specific
way you worded that which adaptation is
better neither they are both terrible
adaptations of the original Source
material they both missed the point
massively as pieces of entertainment I
will grant that the Jim Carrey one is at
least interestingly bad and car crash
fascinating whereas the cumback one
Cumberbatch one is just boring as all
hell so they have different sins they're
both bad movies and they're both
horrible adaptations so I'm not ranking
one over the other Mean Girls is being
remade well technically
it's it's being adapted from the music
musical version that shouldn't have
existed in the first place but this is
the world we live in where movies get
turned into Broadway shows to get turned
into the movies again and the producers
has a lot to answer for at this point I
got to watch the ball drop
probably
uh let's see where was I ah that is the
problem with the Exorcist if you don't
share's foundational beliefs which
blatty did uh but freaking didn't it's
actually not scary like I still have a
suspicion that it was probably still
scary at the time even if you weren't
particularly mering those belie that's
supposition on my part obviously I
wasn't there but like again just where
it was willing to go that other films of
that caliber hadn't gone probably still
shook some people even if they didn't
share the religious beliefs but I think
at this point unless you share that
religiosity uh factor to it then yeah I
have a hard time seeing why anyone will
find it scary now am I excited for
season 1s series4 of Doctor Who with
Davies at the
helm
ah I'm nervously excited uh danger Dave
uh if you've
um if you you've
seen the
uh the latest review I put out I alluded
to the fact that I'm going to have to go
off in a breakroom video which I need to
actually shoot and edit after the live
stream
CA I I am I am very
much
confronted with the fact that RTD is
just going by his old Playbook
that's just what he's doing and I let
him get away with it for the specials
because like if they brought back an old
doctor it was okay for them to have an
older feel um
but at this point almost nothing
indicates that he is going to do what I
wanted from him which is to bring a
which is to not just do what he did in
2005 to bring a different energy to
bring a a more mature more um
artistically refined a different
perspective to it than he did
before I'm just not going to get
that and we'll see how how good um I am
at uh at getting over that I don't know
if I'll be able to that's really gonna
bug
me uh at a raw level
I think it is very likely I will
certainly enjoy it more than chel
Zera but it's also probably going to
have that thorn in my side the whole
time of like I boy would I have
preferred if you were pushing in New
Directions and if he does if he
surprises me that'll be awesome but I
I'm beyond expecting it at this point
for reasons that as I said I I need to I
need to put together a whole other video
on
oh Meg talking about uh about her dog
yeah that that dog that dog it took her
it took her a little while she did she
did uh grow to like me on popular
opinion I like the 2018 Grinch movie
great I'm happy for you I'm glad you did
I was real
bored uh the only Grinch movie I watch
is the OG cartoon
same I saw a wish for wings that work it
was surpris Uris inly sweet for Opus I I
really I was really delighted to be
introduced to that special uh this year
uh actually caroan uh introduced me to
that so um she she won't be joining the
chat uh tonight but um we can thank her
all the
same if you were born in the late 70s
early 80s you're a zenal I'm zenial no
no I'm not no I'm not even finishing
that comment get out of here stop that
stop that I'm an elder Millennial I'm
not I'm not sticking a freaking X in the
middle of no stop
that before he died D&M Banks had an
artist he knew produce artwork of aliens
and
ships in
the series of the culture series oh
that's
Nifty uh live action Grinch lives
rentree in the recesses of my Christmas
despising
mind yeah if you don't care for
Christmas that
movie I mean even if you do care for
Christmas that movie might turn you
around on
that I massively prefer rtd's non who
writing to his who writing so I
understand the reservation about him not
taking a new approach I mean it's just
like I look at what he's done since he
stopped working on Doctor
Who Um or even some of the stuff from
the uh from the tail end of when he
still was you know I look at something
like uh Torchwood children of Earth
which is still Doctor Who related but is
a very different feel I look at
something like it's a sin I haven't seen
years and years but I've I've read a lot
about it I've seen lots of people's
reaction to it and
I see all that and I think that's who I
want to see a new series of Doctor Who
from and I don't think I'm gonna get
that
which just again is just gonna kind of
bum me
out finally got round to reading the
original Sandman Comics I got the books
uh comprising the first 21 issues oh you
still got a way to go my friend there's
great it great as it is does Gremlins 2
count as a Christmas movie no it's not
said at
Christmas
no claiming that Gremlins 2 counts as a
Christmas movie is like
saying excuse me Die Hard with a
Vengeance counts as a Christmas movie
you can have all the debate you want
about the first entry in the series but
that later one no it's not said at
Christmas so
excuse
me if you're looking for a great black
comedy show resident alien on peacock is
great I'm not
really I'm not really looking for
anything right now I am so far behind on
so many things including stuff that I
wanted to see and stuff that I want to
try and give the chance to get better
cuz I tried I tried
watching Scott pilg takes off and it
made me very happy and then it pissed me
off uh the very next episode and I don't
know if I'm gonna have the energy to go
back because I think it's just going to
keep pissing me off um I want I want to
watch poker face that that one I'd like
to see been mean been meaning to find
the
time never have time for this year has
blurred past it's been terrifying
hang on let's
see am I the only one slightly annoyed
that we never got an in Universe
explanation why 13's clothes Chang when
she regenerated into 14 no but once I
found out
the the actual reason why RTD chose to
do that which I don't agree with um I
realized oh you're not you're just just
not gonna you're just not gonna okay
like I think if they were I think if
that was going to be done an explanation
should have been given and I think there
were plenty right there that they could
have gone with um you
know just connecting it somehow to
um the toy maker even there's there's
techno Babble you could have done to do
that but yeah no I I I already made my
piece with the fact that we're not going
to get it why am I getting texted hold
on all
right H let's see Torchwood was so
uneven yeah it was and let's be honest
it was mostly
bad U my mother got me the concept art
book for Christmas when she was looking
for something else on Amazon just
because she was like I remember you like
this writer in this series that was real
nice of
her thank you so much for the latest
great who review do you like the new
doctor being free from the horrors of
the time word Etc that has haunted all
the other recent versions uh honestly
yeah I think they'd probably gotten most
of the actual narrative benefit that was
uh going to be gotten from that I think
I think it was time to move
forward uh Scott Pilgrim again live
action no animated this time Meg what's
wrong with Scott Pilgrim takes off the
problem Black cover is I can't tell you
why it pissed me off without spoiling
its first big like thing the thing that
that has dominated most of the
conversation that if you're familiar
with either the original material or the
movie is is a big change and that's
still new enough and that change is big
enough that I don't just want to blurt
it out but but let me put put it this
way if you've seen the show you'll
probably know what I'm referring to when
I
say
uh the first
episode something that happens near the
very end of that episode got me really
excited and really pumped for what might
come
next and then there's something that
happens at the end of the second episode
that for me at least almost completely
undercut that and pissed me right off
it made me feel like the show pulled a
fast one on me it dangled something
fantastic in front of me and then took
it away it pissed me off again maybe it
works out maybe it does not have uh as
bad a fall on its face after that second
episode as I'm afraid of
but I haven't had the energy to go back
and do more after that second episode it
just really ticked me off that
much I know you don't like a but my Die
Hard is Batman Returns though unlike die
hard I feel I could make a case that
Christmas is thematically relevant to
Batman Returns it's more integrated than
it is in Die Hard I think
honestly
uh terms of sci-fi we do have a really
good time at the moment with the
foundation haven't seen it Silo haven't
seen it Dune first one was only okay and
even despite how garbage it is the new
big name doing IP is Zack Snider's Rebel
Moon haven't seen that either there so
like if this is the big moment for
sci-fi I'm clearly being left behind
since this is the last live stream of
the Year just wanted to wish you a happy
New Year oh thank you Eric I appreciate
that so does Christmas have to be the
central plot for a Christmas movie or
does it just have to be set during
Christmas okay that this is this is the
argument that everybody
has in my
view Christmas should be not necessarily
the central point but it should be
integral
enough that if you set the movie at any
other time of the year it would require
significant alterations and I don't just
mean a couple of sentences or lines
Because unless it requires particularly
deep changes then in my mind that's not
a Christmas movie that's a movie said at
Christmas Die Hard really rides the
borderline on
that
uh yeah I did know that uh Len I did
know that
um God why can't I think of his name now
Alan tudk I knew he was the star of
that will I be reviewing the nth doctor
new big finishes I have big finishes
that I already own that I haven't gotten
to Benjamin I'm I am never going to get
on I'm never going to be able to jump
onto new big finish stuff in a timely
manner ever I'm never gonna have that
kind of
time I'm gonna start doing a shot every
time Vera says no careful
Meg you won't last
long
I'm guessing that A Midsummer Night's
Dream is going to be the surprise
episode for season
two the thing is if with Sandman if they
do what I expect them to
do um no it would have to be part of the
Season
proper because it's my
expectation well okay one of two things
would be the case it would be my
expectation that they would maybe have
that be a danuma
finale
um
because some the I don't want to spoil
it for you Rowan there is a particular
element that's going to come back up and
is going to matter with What would most
likely be a third season
story
um and I can't really explain to you
what that is now technically they could
do without it like you could do the
narrative without that element
but uh just given some of the notes that
the main series ends on I I expect
they'll integrate it in
proper have you seen the Santa Clauses
on Disney plus nope I absolutely have
not and I do not care and no it's not an
anti- Tim Allen thing I just like the
first movie is fine I've never seen any
of the sequels I have no interest in
this like why are there more why is
there more than in the one movie I don't
know and I don't care enough to find out
on Torchwood mostly bad have you still
to watch Miracle day I have not seen
Miracle day yet I am comfortable in
saying that Torchwood is mostly bad
based solely on series 1 Series 2 in
Children of
Earth do you think 14 is Don or he'll
return in the immediate distant future
so 14 meaning the 14th Doctor David
hennet second go I don't want want him
to ever come back he's done he has his
happy ending leave him
alone will he ever come back I mean
maybe I don't want him to
though Scott Pilgrim takes off works out
well whether or not it works out depends
on how it addresses my problem and from
at least the very few conversations I've
had with people who have seen it all the
way through when I point pointed out my
problem and the thing that pissed me
off
um I kind of got a yeah you might still
be pissed
off
ah all right okay so
here's here's the thing here's the thing
benjamen what I want
wanted based off what happened at the
end of that first episode was a
completely new Direction and I honestly
thought they were going to do that but
instead the backpedal at the end of
episode two says to me that stuff that I
would happily leave behind and see the
entire thing move on and away from as
fast as possible is still going to be
present and to have it continue to be
present at all in in that fashion
already ticks me
off like it
is the end of episode one was a slap in
the face in a good
way and the end of episode
two
was was going like yeah we might smacky
again and then
just oh that's all you're going to do
the rest of this time aren't you great
you shouldn't have told me I was going
to get smacked around I was looking
forward to that that's more information
than I should be giving let's move
on anyone get drag race Vibes when the
toy maker lip syn spice up your life no
not really I mean is it vaguely drag
Queeny yes
but like drag race specifically no they
don't know a patent on lip sync I'm
sorry I I I I'm at a point where I'm
just annoyed that drag race specifically
is shorthand for drag performance cuz
no that show is actually shockingly
Limited in
scope
so that my annoyance has nothing to do
with you I'm nervous about how a game of
you is going to be adapted in season
two
uh only slightly only slightly because
gaming seems to be very aware of what
the issues
were all right purple Raider and then I
have to hop over to the Discord and then
I'll be
back excuse me purple Raider thank you
for the Super Chat I watch the second
Octor story The Mind robber on Christmas
Eve and I loved it have you seen it what
are your thoughts I have seen it I have
a review up in the break room of Geeks
it's a good time boy it's
weird um so I'm gonna hop over to the
Discord real quick because that is the
other place where you can ask me
questions and I'm guaranteed to see them
uh it is a patreon exclusive perk so I'm
going to hop over and uh take a look at
that I will be back as quickly as I can
be after answering those questions um
feel free to keep talking in the chat
just be aware that it's pretty much
guaranteed I am not going to see your
comment coming back unless it is as a
super chat because those will be
highlighted for me otherwise I'm just
gonna have to jump to the end of the
chat and pick it up from when I get back
anyways here we go on the Discord H wow
that's a fair few all right here we go
recently I heard of view Express that
most Doctor Who companions are fridged I
point out that's numerically not the
case especially if you include the
classic series but it does seem like new
who's more melodramatic leanings do
involve more tragic departures do you
have any thoughts on tragic companion
departures and fridging well the first
thing is I would argue none of the
companions have been fridged let's make
a distinction right off the
bat a tragic end or even a death of a
character is not the same as frigging
frigging is a very specific kind of
death of a character it is the death of
a character through usually woman though
not always but it is the death or
brutalization of a character through
cruel and
unnecessarily harsh means like the story
does not require that it be this brutal
but it is and the main purpose of doing
it is not to affect that character story
but to impact other characters in the
story usually men so the most common
situation is a girlfriend wife fiance
Etc
of a hero character
being assaulted murdered tortured
whatever to motivate that male hero to
seek revenge go and
rescue Etc like it's more than just a
damsel and distress thing it's it's far
far worse but I would argue Doctor Who
has not fridged any of the companions
because even when a companion has a
harsh ending that is an ending to their
story it's not being done strictly for
the purposes of impacting the doctor's
story it will impact the doctor they
have a relationship it should but it's
not being done primarily for that
purpose the The Telltale sign of
fridging is if in the
aftermath is any Focus um given to the
sense of closure or what happen since to
that person or is pretty much all the
focus on just how it impacted everybody
else and not actually much of a thought
about what was lost by having lost that
person but just like well how do how did
this make all them feel and so I would
say dror was never frigid his companions
modern erod Doctor Who does have a
tendency to force the companions to
leave by one means or another be it
death or be it um just force
circumstances like um Rose getting
trapped in the other dimension I've
mentioned before I don't like how much
modern era doctor who does this again
it's not a fridging thing it just has
for me to do it's kind of an impact of
the modern era pretty much all having
been written or at least showrun by
people who are previously fans of the
show and I think the problem is fans of
the show have a hard time imagining why
anyone would choose to stop traveling in
the Tardis and since they can't think of
a reason why someone would just stop
they tend to as a result force them out
by often very traumatic means so that I
I don't I don't have a problem with it
happening it has become
the standard uh or at least it was for a
while in the modern era that was one of
the things I'll give chibnall credit for
he didn't do that with any of the
companions that I'll give him credit for
that that was a nice break I'm not
thrilled at the idea that we'll leap
back into it we'll
see with regard to the James Summerton
thing oh God and His so-called apology
and how we leftist should react to it
would you agree the idea of uh
Reformation Redemption needs to be
separated from the idea of ever trusting
him as video essayist in the future a
lot of responses I've seen are like well
I hope he's well and can reform but I
still think he should never make any
videos I kind of compare to a scenario
where an alcoholic surgeon kills a
patient because he was drunk like I want
him to get reformed and get over his
addiction but uh it'd be responsible to
be like okay I want you to get better
but you should never be a doctor ever
again yeah that's basically where I'm at
James Summerton has no business ever
making videos ever ever ever ever again
and his apology was crap I saw 5 minutes
of it and couldn't stomach listening to
him anymore and I read the transcript of
the left of of the rest he barely
apologized at all he didn't really he
centered his own pain front and center
uh which is a big red flag I'm not going
to question his sincerity and what he
said about what he was going through if
he was being sincere I hope he gets the
help that he needs and gets to a better
place but even if it was sincere
frontloading that in the beginning is
that is a a technique that minimizes the
impact of what you did and minimizes
your wrongdoing by centering your pain
and I'm not trying to invalidate his
pain
but opening with that was a massive red
flag but yes overall I agree with you
like the simple thing is dude don't try
and get back into videos you have a
business degree go into business leave
us
alone you have every right to a
livelihood a future and the chance to be
better but you have proven you are not
to be trusted with this line of work go
away do you think casting directors who
are usually white on biopic and
historicals make less of an effort
actually getting someone who looks like
the person they're supposed to be
playing if it's a non-white person
because they assume that if they at
least get someone who's the right
ethnicity it's close enough one of my
favorite TV movies is an LBJ bile piic
called all the way in one aspect of it
uh that was kind of weird is they cast
Anthony Macky as Martin Luther King he's
both thinner and taller than King was I
have to wonder if they'd have cast
someone that physically different with a
white historical figure the thing is
like I get the point that you're making
and does that happen
maybe but also to a degree I'm someone
who doesn't think that the uh
specificity of the physical nature of a
person and like Race Matters more often
than not um especially with someone like
Martin Luther King Jor uh but by and
large like the specifics of height the
specifics of build you know
that unless that was particularly key to
the part of their story you're putting
in the biopic that's the kind of thing I
I just don't get hung up on anyway like
try try and capture the essence of the
person um if there is reference material
for you to do so and if it's a
historical figure for so far back that
there isn't a lot of reference material
just try and give a good performance
like I feel like looking more like the
person is the least interesting basis to
be casting on in terms of like the
specifics of of oh you you're like same
height same build same facial structure
like okay but can you play the
part A while back I read a Sci-Fi book
about a general who took part in uh
World War where he ended up murdering
his steps sister who came to his Camp to
reason with him and sending her remains
back to the other General her
stepbrother I.E her blood brother sorry
his step
brother okay uh In Cold Blood on the
calculation that destroy him and without
a functional Commander the opposing Army
would collapse the bulk of the novel is
him traveling around the Galaxy for
centuries trying to do good after he
realized how terrible his actions were
do you think you could ever sympathize
with a protagonist like that I have no
idea it would depend whol on the quality
of the writing and the degree to which
it is able to um get me into the
perspective of of a person like that
like you
you that is a pitch that is difficult to
do and would depend entirely on the
execution of the entirety of the novel
so I absolutely cannot judge that based
off a log line I just
can't uh what's the oldest video game uh
any console or PC that you still play
and still enjoy mine is Sid Meers
colonization from
1994 which I still play today um I think
the
oldest thing that I still tou like I I
still touch like steam ports of some of
my old Super Nintendo games like uh Mega
Man X or Ninja Turtles turtles and th um
chono Trigger or a few others do you
have any specific things you prepare eat
during the Christmas holiday season uh
thankfully I don't do the cooking
um they are lovely meals that I get to
enjoy I don't do the cooking
um and it's not always the same thing
have you ever watched any of the movies
or read any of the comics written by
Alejandro
Yosi such as the movie El Topo or the
comics in cantal or and or the
metabarons the latter two set in the
same universe there's documentary called
yosi's Dune which documents his attempt
to First make uh the movie adaptation of
Dune in the mid 70s I've not seen any of
his movies or read any of his things I
have seen yosi's d I've seen that
documentary it is fascinating it is a
fascinating movie and I'm slightly
envious of the people who live in the
timeline where he got to make that movie
what will your criteria be for ranking
the Doctor Who specials will minisodes
like night of the doctor be included I
will not be including minisodes I am I
am only going to be doing modern era and
I am going to be uh doing basically
anything that's not part of a series
proper so that includes the New Year
specials the Christmas specials the um
the anniversary specials and also just
the stuff the the weird it it's kind of
a of a fifth series but it's called the
specials that David Tenant did after
series 4 like that's the stuff that'll
be included do you think Russell T
Davies should apologize to Eon for the
way he was
treated that is between the two of them
I don't think eckl would accept an
apology at this point I don't know if
Russell has ever tried
I I think it would be nice if two
creatively minded people could come to
terms and be okay with each other but it
they have personal reasons for being in
the positions that they're in and I'm
not going to say what Russell should or
shouldn't do or whether or not it would
help uh what is it about Kang's reveal
in lowkey that you think worked better
than Agatha Harkness Kingpin and the
flag Smashers
um well the main thing is that Kang
actually
fit um Agatha Harkness doesn't work
because she comes out of freaking
nowhere and is not only not um a
compliment to the themes of w division
she's actively distracting from them so
Agatha was a freaking disaster kingpin's
not really a problem when he shows up
but he's just kind of there the story
doesn't need him
uh Kang was needed at the end of the
first season of Loki somebody needed to
be there so um and then with the flag
Smashers they fit and they fit the
thematics they just fell down on the
execution that's where that one went
wrong so Kang was just the culmination
of everything that needed to happen he
needed to be there for the narrative he
fit the themes he actually bolstered the
themes by his nature and what he did and
what he said and I felt in in that last
episode of the first season of Loki he
was very well executed from both a
writing and a performance standpoint
don't ask me about Jonathan Majors I
don't want to talk about it but within
the confines of that episode he just
like all three things came into
play it the character should be there he
fit and complimented the themes and it
was well executed the other three you
mentioned fell down on at least one of
those
points should Joseph C
Campbell's monomyth be completely
deconstructed or shed altogether or
should it be preserved and analyzed I
feel like people should just stop
referencing it as a thing definitely
stop using it as a template for how to
tell stories like here's the thing about
the monomyth the monomyth in theory if
it was even accurate
which but even if it was in theory this
is a format that stories just naturally
take so we shouldn't need to be
referencing it your story will take on
certain elements of the monomyth kind of
against your own will because it's in
theory so embedded in our uh Collective
unconscious and our societal nature of
Storytelling that you don't need to keep
referencing and deliberately evoking the
damn thing so leave it alone that's that
is my view I don't think it is worth
deliberately deconstructing and I
definitely do not think it should be
anything anybody should be referencing
as a template for how to tell stories
unless you want a very Bland generic
story that everybody's seen already a
thousand times which is better New
Year's or Christmas depends on how much
alcohol you have on hand if I was doing
an Old World style Christmas visit which
is better New York City Boston or
Baltimore I don't know what oldw World
style Christ Christmas visit
means I I don't understand the
question I would not want to be in any
of those cities on on uh Christmas
and I lived in two of
them uh how long do you think they will
keep the mavity gag going at least for
as long as uh RTD is in charge what is a
question that you are surprised you've
never been asked on a live
stream that is a great question that I
wish I had an answer
to because there probably are some but I
I'm now going to struggle and draw
blank
yeah I don't know that is a great
question but I also don't know uh which
would you rather rewatch if forced last
Christmas or
cats am I allowed to
drink if I'm allowed to drink then cats
uh if I'm not than last
Christmas all right so I am back in the
main chat now thank thank you very much
for your
patience no o there's a super chat I was
going to say no super chats came in then
somebody snuck in there Richard D thank
you very much for the Super Chat what do
you think of the character of Captain
Mike
Yates so hash rip Richard Franklin so
here's the thing
um I haven't seen seen the stories in
which he appears I don't think or I've
only seen a couple hang on let me get a
list let me get a list on him all right
I've seen teror of the
aons I've seen Claus of
axos all right I've only
seen
um three of the stories he's been
involved in and he didn't leave a
massive impression on me um Terra the
aons I don't remember him Claus of axos
I that I watched that so long ago I need
to rewatch it before I can do a review
of it uh planet of the spiders I don't
remember him I remember in general
thinking that you know having a
recurring some recurring characters
within unit was always a good thing so
I'm going to tentatively say that his
presence was a welcome addition but for
the ones I've actually seen that he's
appeared in he is not in particular
leaping to mind at this time I still
have a fair amount of third doctor stuff
to get through though um so bear that in
mind oh and also that is apparently your
first Super Chat on a live stream so
thank you very
much the mavity joke was so stupid
it's it's not worth getting upset over
it's kind of where I'm at with it like
do I think it's funny no it just doesn't
seem worth getting worked up about
a lot of people I know online are are
queer or anxious about being fat or
whatever they told me I'm lucky I like
my body even if I have other issues I
mean yeah but somebody telling you that
can can feel like they're kind of
telling you stop
complaining and they rarely mean it that
way but it's like well you know at least
you don't have this or you don't have
that like none of that does anything to
fix the problems where that you have
like it it's like it's like when
somebody um when you're like well how
are how are things like well they could
be worse I'm like that doesn't tell me
anything they could always be worse that
doesn't mean they aren't bad now so
especially if somebody tries to tell you
well it could be worse as a way to try
and cheer you up that doesn't freaking
help so I'm sure I'm sure a lot of those
people that you know meant well but that
kind of thing frustrates me like just
because somebody is not experiencing one
type of um anxiety or discomfort or
struggle in their life that doesn't make
their life easier than you it just means
they have different
struggles
yeah I wish we had Real Life Council of
Geeks meet up I like talking with y'all
I I have I have toyed vaguely like um
when I've been in La for gal ofray 1 or
what have you trying to organize a a
Meetup you know when I've been in larger
areas uh I haven't largely just because
uh the logistics would melt my brain and
stress me out
so that's that's an unlikely thing to
happen unless somebody else organized it
uh no is Wicked Wolf I don't the demons
is one of the best Third Doctor stories
I still haven't seen that
one uh there there's
a there's a fair uh bit of well classic
in general that I still need to see and
a lot of fourth doctor stuff but that's
because he he was on the show for
so so dang
long it's pretty messed up how could be
worse SL don't worry about it SL it'll
be fine Etc are so normalized as a
response to anything bad yeah and again
I don't think the people who say that
ever mean anything bad by
it I I think it's
um I think it's just a matter
of you you get that sense of well we
can't do anything about it so you you
try and offer a perspective to someone
well maybe this will help because we
can't fix it but you know it usually
doesn't
because you can't just fix it but it it
can make things sometimes feel worse if
you feel if you end up feeling like well
you're not even taking what I am going
through
seriously uh yeah
it if you can find somebody to validate
your
experiences that is that's a powerful
thing uh so you
know
H Los Angeles is pretty far from me it's
pretty far from me too to be
Fair I'd love to do a Meetup but I get
too shy and I'm just a Wallflower see
like a big part of why I would never
organize one is I would be paranoid that
I would show up and nobody else would
and my self-esteem would just
[Music]
go does Disney own Doctor Who now no no
they don't did a whole video on that
freaking last year I think I did a video
on that no they
don't
uh
which doctor has the best
costume I don't
know I tell you the one I enjoy
cosplaying the most out of the costumes
I have is
um I don't know though like I I I go up
and down on that I did a ranking on best
doct costumes a little while ago I don't
even remember what I said and this is
the thing about those rankings like I
don't memorize them and it's not like I
must remember this is my number one for
always like no that was my number one at
the time I made it maybe if I made it
again it'd be something else but I don't
have an answer off the top of my head
but there is a video you can check out
in the back
catalog you wouldn't like me in person
no one does hey
he
hey I'm not going to tell you you need
to change the way that you think about
yourself what I am going to say
is in this space I would strongly
encourage you to not verbalize putting
yourself down in that manner because I
don't think anybody in here would agree
with
you
and it is my hope
that the less you put those words
forward maybe the less you'll feel
them that may or may not end up being
the
case but I
hope that you won't take this as me
condemning
you I hope that you will recognize that
what I'm attempting to do in saying this
is say that
that your feelings about
yourself they might be whatever they are
but that does not mean that is how
everyone else sees you and that goes in
all directions if you think you're
amazing not everybody does if you think
you're awful not everybody
does don't assume
that everyone shares the view of you
that you have of yourself or even if you
don't NE necessarily have that do not
project outwards the worst possible view
is universally shared about you because
I promise you that's not
true uh let's
see having heard his music in the tutors
Dragon Age and uh the Netflix
Castlevania I think Trevor Morris should
do music for Doctor Who after Murray go
leaves the show again I'm like I'll just
be I'll be okay okay if Murray decides
he only wanted to come back for one
series what's my music taste I do not
have a uh
Punchy uh way to describe it as far as
songs go I tend to favor Pop I like I
like upbeat music a lot of the time but
like that's not a universal rule it's
all over the place is 15 wearing a skirt
or a kilt it's a
kilt The Fugitive doctor I love that top
it's a good look been a hoian since 1979
first episode I saw was the reos
operation it took a year before PBS
showed it in Louisiana my favorite
doctor was Tom Baker Tom Baker was good
and that was a good time to come in on
because that was uh the key to time
which is good stuff sorry ver I was
being glib I
know I I know Black cover
and I don't want to give the impression
that
um you shouldn't you know be allowed to
be glib
but I don't know I'm trying to put down
myself less and I have felt better since
making that
move
and I don't know it's something I I hope
for for other
people I wouldn't get to meet up unless
Vera does an international tour
uh
yeah don't know how likely that
is uh unless you have answered that
before since they will be showing up in
the upcoming series of Doctor Who what
is your opinion on the
Beatles very important band I don't like
them nearly as much as anybody else does
I'm not going to call them overrated
because that would be inaccurate they're
very important they're very influential
the shape of Music would not be what it
currently is without them
however I don't like them nearly as much
as everybody else does and I'm really
hoping they don't get deified in this
thing let's go with
that I was wondering what you thought
about the Timeless child reference in
the new episode I'm happy to see the
show actually do something with the ESS
child yeah I mean like same thing that I
said about the um the episode wild blue
yonder
um the RTD with small references is
doing more about how that those
Revelations impacted the doctor than
chel did at
all like see all right I need to wrap up
soon but I am G to go off on this for a
hot minute this is what really ticked me
off about
chipn I didn't
like the Timeless child I didn't like it
as an idea I immediately didn't like it
however when I talked about it around
the time that it happened I very
frequently put a caveat on my dislike of
it saying that I still think this is a
bad idea however I said very
emphatically I don't think it should be
immediately reccon I think chibo should
be allowed to tell whatever story it is
he has that that he tends to weave
coming out of this whatever story he
thinks doing this will enable him to
tell I want to see what that is that
turned out to
be I'm going to swear on stream now so
there's your heads up up [__]
nothing that's that more than anything
is what infuriates me about chibal time
on Doctor Who not just the things he
chose to do not just the choices he made
not just the writing not being up to
Snuff a lot of the time but he would do
things that should matter you completely
upended the doctor's understanding of
thems
and it didn't matter you destroyed half
the goddamn universe and it didn't
matter why are you doing these things if
you're not going to build stories out of
the things that you are doing I
fundamentally as a person who is also a
writer as a person with further creative
Ambitions as a person who has a passion
to tell stories I do not understand a
Storyteller who would do do these things
and then build
nothing with
them I don't understand in a way that
infuriates
me like I don't want to get speculative
about it I'm not going to claim that
this is the case but if
somebody if Chris chel in five years
ever says you you know I never really
wanted the Doctor Who gig but they asked
me and uh nobody else was stepping up to
take it so I I took it just to be sure
the show went going if he ever said that
I wouldn't call him a liar because there
was a distinct lack of
passion in his work from him
specifically not from anybody else but
from him
Council of Gees World Tour style
H there's kind of a
uh there's a tour I kind of want to do
about around the New England East Coast
area but that wouldn't be Council of
Geeks related
that that if it happens would be
a whole other thing I will leave it at
that self uh deprecation is quite
poisonous kind of a fake it tell you
make it type deal even if you genuinely
dislike yourself lie about it until you
believe the lie is stronger than you
believe
dislike I mean like certainly try that
that doesn't work for everyone but yeah
I do think that continually vocalizing
even as a joke Your Own Worst thoughts
about yourself make them feel more
tangible for a lot of us I watched 1985
Santa Claus the Movie for the first time
didn't really understand why that's
hated it's certainly better than
Supergirl which was from the same
director I don't I don't remember it
being hated I
think um I think at this point it's just
largely forgotten that that
happened uh how often do you explore new
series I love diving into weird unknown
stuff Carol and the end of the world
really surprised me uh not that
often uh ndian because
um I don't have the
time this job pretty heavily dictates
what I spend my time
doing um and generally when I'm not
doing something related to this job and
this work um then I'm not watching
anything at all because you know when
I'm
with um you know whether it's it's my
boyfriend my girlfriend my partner when
I'm when I'm with somebody I'm I'm there
to be with them and sometimes we'll
watch stuff together
but I'm usually more focused on just
enjoying my time with them so most of my
time that isn't spent literally away
from my house and out of physically out
of my office is spent with my partners
or with my
kid
and that means that the rest of the time
the time that I could actually
theoretically be watching something um
um I'm I'm working so if I'm watching
something it's probably work
related I get to things occasionally but
I don't have that much free time uh in
terms of like being able to just just go
oh that looks weird and interesting I'll
check that out like I don't have that I
like especially given how behind I am
and how much stuff I'm be I'm am so far
behind on commission
reviews that sitting down and going oo I
have some free time I'll check out this
thing that I've never done before a part
of my brain is going to go do you know
how long the list of stuff you said
you'd review or you've been paid to
review and you haven't yet is get off
your ass and watch that
instead this this is the life I made for
myself that's a rod I made for my own
back who's the most irritating character
that a show wanted you to root for
uh it's not a show but it he was
recurring enough that I'm going to count
him Damen Wayne in the animated uh DC
movies God did I hate that
kid I just realized this will be the
first time I'm older than the actress
playing the doctor and companion do you
feel similar um I don't know if this is
the first time for me or not I'm I'm the
same age as Matt
Smith so I've had that
experience uh hang on a
second
and I'm the same age as jod Whitaker too
so I I guess this is the
uh this is the first time that the
doctor has been strictly speaking
younger than me um
but like I kind of came to terms with
the idea that the that the doctor was my
age already and so that this feels like
a small step from that
can't stay just jumped in to wish you a
happy New Year thank you
Christie uh any ideas already when will
be the first live stream of the new year
um well these are every two weeks so
that should be the ninth uh for that I
know I have a couple of um super chats
to get to and then I got to wrap it up
um have you or are you planning to see
Wonka I have not and I am not I'm I'm
just not interested I've heard it's fine
I've heard it's fine I'm sure it is I
just have no
interest Supreme
Omega uh on 2023 it's interesting the IP
driven films have decayed the
controversy and disinterest while the
Standalone a films have been more
popular I
[Music]
mean
ah I I feel like we're kind of bending
the notion of Standalone uh
um because like hang on let me pull up
the big movies of the Year Barbie based
on an existing IP Super Mario Brothers
based on an existing IP Oppenheimer okay
I'll give you that one Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 fast 10 Spider-Man
across the
spiderverse full River red oh that's a
Chinese movie the wandering Earth to all
right those are both Chinese movies I
don't know those little mermaid Mission
possible dead reckoning part one like I
think we had a lot more high-profile
flops this year but I'm not sure I would
argue that
like aut
tourism has made some kind of bold
comeback I think I feel like that might
be preemptive that said I am planning in
the new year to go off on uh our our IP
driven present I was going to say Future
No it's our present present this is just
what we
have all right purple
Raider excuse me came back again with
another Super Chat very much appreciated
very
generous I love the way you think about
media you talk about things with such
detail and intelligence that even when I
don't agree with you on something I know
exactly what thought process you went
through to get there thank you I
actually that's one of my favorite
things to hear because I don't expect
everyone to agree with me it'd be a
boring world if they did but I figure
the least I can do as a basic metric for
me being good at this job is that
somebody can at least understand why I
landed on a different conclusion than
they did even if they think I'm wrong if
I can explain myself well well enough
that you know how I got the answer I did
even if you disagree with that answer
then I think I'm doing okay at this
job heading off for now hope you have a
happy New Year thank you Rowan I should
wrap it up
too you say well drinking your trademark
water well th this would be the
trademark water
um this is this is however currently
empty I got a Rectify
that anyways I do need to wrap it up
thank you um all very much for joining
me uh I hope you have had a lovely year
and if you didn't I hope that you have a
better new one so stuff coming
up tomorrow I am streaming on Twitch
10:30 uh back to balers Gate
3 later on this
week hopefully yeah probably tomorrow
I'll also have a new video up in the
breakroom going off on a specific aspect
of the uh new Russell Z Davis era of
Doctor Who that
I'm um and then I've got some other
stuff that'll be up in the break room
before the end of the year a review of
the Third Doctor story Carnival of the
monsters that'll go up uh later on
probably in the new year I will have
reviews going up for things like the
third season of Hilda and Indiana Jones
in the dial of
Destiny
um and some other stuff but that that's
what's coming up in the immediate future
uh Saturday's video here on this channel
is going to be my picks for the 10 best
pieces of entertainment uh of 2023 and
then we jump into the new year so thank
you all for joining me yes art I will be
at galif Fray 1 in in February I'll
start uh hyping that up as we once we
get into the new year I'll start hyping
that up more but yes I am going to be in
Los Angeles for the yif FR 1 convention
uh in 2024 and I am very much looking
forward to it so thank you very much all
for joining me and be well be safe and
be kind and please remember that you are
beautiful you are
valid you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the
meetings and until next time this
council is
adjourned
mavity